hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast whole-genome identification of
crisper targets presented by dr. Dmitry
Perry a senior lecturer and science and
engineering faculty in electrical
engineering computer science and data
science at Queensland University of
Technology
I'm dr. Susie Valdes of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth lab Rhodes is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that ask a question box on the far
left of your screen type the questions
into the Dropbox the on box and app that
appear on the screen and our speaker
will respond to your questions via email
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
that ask a question box and let us know
you're having some trouble this
presentation is educational and best
offers education credits please click on
the continuing education credit tab at
the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits without
further ado please join me now in
welcoming our presenter dr. Dmitry
parrying I will now turn the
presentation over to him dr. Breen
welcome and thank you for joining thank
you for the introduction and so today
I'm going to talk to you about more
computational sides of looking at CRISPR
and I'm going to talk about how we can
design algorithms to identify and good
Chris protagonist in an entire genome so
DM the way the talking is structured is
that I will start by giving you a
briefing and background and motivation
as to why we want to identify these
targets and in entire chinos then I will
explain
in the specific context of knockouts
with your targeting strategy with
developed then I'm going to explain how
when our algorithm is filtering targets
that we only select what we think are
going to be good targets I will show you
some results in the sleep context and I
will explain the types of challenges we
currently trying to solve so just to
give you some initial background i'm
currently based at Queensland University
of Technology in Australia but I started
working with CRISPR when I was sitting
in Japan in a group that is focused on
second Balaji in steel and in that feels
like in many other fields researchers
rely heavily on knockouts especially
using mouse or fruit flies and other
organisms to study specific genes so for
instance his famous paper from Shannon
SIG's looking at would be more on
knockouts just release importance for
the sickening clock similarly this paper
from 2011 on cry 1 and so because of
that few Lions on knockouts for a long
time the progress was slowed down right
that's from a milestone account
generation because it can be a
relatively long process for each
generation in knockouts and I'm
processing it takes roughly three months
and you have multiple crossing to obtain
TM reality knockouts that you're looking
for so in that context any method that
can help accelerate that knockout
generation process is likely to have a
very significant and very positive
impact in CRISPR in the lake was just
the latest in a long list of tools
people's confused zinc fingers talons
and so on and the main advantage which
Kris Pearn in theory was the ease of use
and TM potential efficiency of 50 method
so DM that's why I pick people who got
very excited about technique
that's how we started working in that
base Reina nice but what we found by
when we studied about five years ago was
that DM in the first generation DM mice
that who were looking at contains a
mosaic of wild-type and the cat cells
and GM right of companies billions and
billions relatively low it was around 60
to 80 percenter at best and also it's
even though if we have a good crisp
attack and the results are promising
it's actually not that easy to design a
good targets and so Thiele based on all
that our objective was to develop the
methods that we can detect um targets
that will be efficient and safe so we
define these two terms in just a moment
patoot that's of detection strategy to
develop an algorithm that will detect
targets in the entire genome that one of
the objectives in doing that was to
increase the reproducibility of the work
and also to make all TM targets that we
identified publicly available so
introduced to properties and efficiency
and safety so we'll give you more
details but what I mean exactly so in
terms of wish if you can see well if you
have a low not a deficiency in a way
you're only getting half of the promised
benefits of CRISPR of course you still
have the ease of use which is nice a
nice to have a technique that's
relatively easy to use but what we also
want to eliminate if we want to
accelerate the development of the these
neutrons is the need for crossing over
multiple generations because that's
what's really taking a lot a lot of time
so what we want to achieve is highly
efficient
prediction of whole body completely
knockouts in a single generation and
when we mean we mean by highly highly
efficient is that we would like at least
90% of the offspring to be a complete
knockout to achieve that we need to rely
on the
direction of the targets so you need to
be careful about which targets we're
going to use but in the knockout context
we can also play with the actual
targeting strategy and so we cover these
two aspects during the presentation the
other aspects is TM safety of TM targets
of course we want to knock out a team so
we want to be efficient in knocking out
that chain but we also want to make sure
that the guides that we generate are not
going to make a modification somewhere
else in the genome but otherwise well if
we observe an interesting phenotype we
have no way to know if that phenotype is
the result of the gene that we're
knocking out or if it's just a side
effects on an unexpected medication
someone else in the genome so that means
first that we need to exclude targets
that occur in multiple locations in the
genome because we have no way to know
where it's going to cut which we also
want to eliminate targets that have
partial matches in multiple places in
the genome because it has been shown
that the guide RNA doesn't need to have
a perfect match to the sequence in order
to - to bind them so we need to take
these two aspects and I'm into account
our perspective is that we have to be
very strict about this even if it means
excluding many potential targets that's
especially going to be true in terms of
possible long-term application of of
crispers of Crystal methods um in the
context of what the groupie is doing in
second and biology well it would be I
mean it is bad if we have enough targets
modification that leads to us being
misled in when we studying a specific
phenotype but I mean in a way we can
it's just going to delay our own
research but in some applications in
health or in crop modifications wealthy
impacts would be much larger if we have
unpredicted after again modification so
that's why we took an approach to be
very strict about
targets that we felt had a risk of of
targets modifications and of course when
the assays we need to ensure that guides
don't lead to effective modifications
and was difficult to really guarantee
these but what we try to do is um
minimize the risk as much as possible so
that's what what I meant when I said we
want targets are going to be efficient
and safe the other thing I mentioned
distance in the context of an account we
can't play with the m2 design of the
targets but also with D targeting
strategy itself what I mean by that is
that we there's nothing stopping us from
targeting multiple sites in the same
gene that we targeted trying to to knock
outs and so we have a nice little model
that tried to explain why that that
could be a good idea and so the idea is
that of course you have multiple
processes that are involved in when you
using CRISPR but if you have a very
simple description of what happening you
can describe TM deficiency of utopia
knockout as the ratio between your
concentration and forget RNA MDM
dissociation constant plus stats
concentration and that's if you use one
target but if you use multiple guide
RNAs for the same chain while what you
have is that the probability that you're
getting is going to be one minus the
probability that you don't make a cut
anywhere else so for instance if we if
you have three if you targeting three
positions in the same genome you get
stats and equation and at the bottom of
course the only time in 13 is 2 only
half of the of what's happening the
other side is that there is a recovery
rate the actor repair mechanisms and so
it might be that you're making a curve
but that TM repair from your curves is
actually not leading to an Indian ethnic
ads um and so we measure that I mean we
take that into account with our
parameter alpha which we
this rabbit has the recovery rate from
that girl's anything that the
probability of having occurred is going
to be that's ratio we had before s over
k plus s multiplied by 1 minus alpha
that's for just one side and as before
we can extend that and so if we have
three antagonists forget the formula at
the bottom but we can generalize it to
any number of targets and we can so
that's complex looking equator at the
bottom which might look slightly scary
at first but the interesting thing is
that what all these parameters we can
either measure them or just estimate
them and just have simulations of what
the expected efficiency will be and so
the interesting thing is that we get
results like this where for fixed guide
RNA concentration the more guides you
use to more efficient the knockouts is
likely to be of course you have
diminishing returns so if you use two
guides instead of one get a big jump in
the efficiency if you use three instead
of two it gets it gets better again but
then at some moment if you use 25
carrots instead of 24 one test that much
of a difference mmm
insert the mid-20 self something
practical also the value we settled on
was to use three targets so to use
triple tank targeting so that's what we
tried first for dm0 CNAs gene which is a
gene that's responsible for TM the black
color of the fur optimize and so we
designed three different targets for
that chain in so zero one two and three
and so you can see at the top of TM and
image for e for each targets used
individually TM the
and my star completely wise the
efficiency is between 36 to 65% which is
in line with what we expected at the
time but the interesting thing is if you
deliver all targets at the same time
into the same embryo then all but one of
the of the burbs are completely white
and that and so we had 40 perhaps in the
offspring internal also that means in
97.5%
first generation double knockout sorry
Bailey Nick knockouts and efficiency so
we were very exciting about that but in
a way it's a blessing and a curse
because I mean the blessing side is that
well it's looks like it's going to be
very highly efficient we can generate no
Galax in the first generation very
efficiently so that's very exciting um
but there are two limitations well the
first one the main one is that for each
chain that we want to target using that
strategy well instead of using one
targets that we use three targets so if
it was tricky to design one target it's
going to be even trickier to design
three good targets the other thing that
we have to remember is that what we want
targets that will minimize the risk of
of targets of target modification and of
course if the more targets we use the
more likely it is that there is going to
be enough target risk and who use three
targets we multiply the risk of target
modifications as as well and so that
means that these strategy of triple
targeting for knockout only becomes a
practical solution if we have a way to
quickly detect and quickly identify good
targets and then ideally save them once
we detected them for the whole genomes
at anytime we want to target a new gene
we very quickly have access to good
targets and so that's where we got the
EM the motivation to design an automated
method to do that
so the
questions we asked ourselves is well
what does a crisper target look like
anyway enter DM
basic pool that's of I got from my Extra
metal colleagues was that what we're
looking for
damn the sequins that had a fixed lens
studied with a chi and with GG and that
for Nike I didn't really care which
trends and that target work was located
in practice they were so little bit
flexible about what they were looking
for they told me well it can start with
a or C it's fine but what's really
important is that as I said before the
test sequence is going to be unique and
they also told me what the secondary
structure is going to be importers and
get back to that in a few minutes
and also TM we want to be careful about
the off target effects as I mentioned
multiple times already
and so that sort of gave give me the
initial skillets and vote for what we
wanted to do and so based on these
initial guidelines I started to develop
a detect detection method so the
objective is to have a method that we
take as an input machine ohm and we
detect all the targets for all the
chains in that genome so it's a slightly
different approach to some tools that we
six into an on-the-fly detection work
you provide a sequence 10 25 targets
just for that sequence um the reason why
we used the whole genome detection is
that well in the lab they were different
people interested in different genes and
then we realized that for many people
different groups will be interested in
backing off resource they would all have
different interests so it just made
sense to just process the gene the
genome all at once and just save the
results it's more more efficient in
terms of the technical details TM method
is implemented in Python and in C and
using some also some third-party tools
like bowtie for instance for for
alignments the way instead of we can
detect targets for a specific gene if we
really want to just work on on a gene
or the list of gene or the whole genome
and in practice because of memory
limitations the way the whole genomes
against detection works is that we take
TM list of genes for the genome we
create the list of 20 to 25 genes and
then we process the one list at a time
just because otherwise we have some
memory issues when we run the methods
and instead the Internet's few slides
I'm going to detail had that detection
method and works for one gene it would
be the same maybe city what we detecting
for the whole genome it's the same
process you just do that for every
single gene and so I'm going to assume
that we detect targets for just one gene
then detail that's exactly what the
matter is doing for that hypothetical
gene so DM in the first step what we're
doing is that we want to extract all the
possible targets for that gene that
we're targeting so what we do is that
for all suitable exons we extract all
the targets that match the basic pattern
that's my colleagues were looking for
which is something that starts with a c
OG then has 20 any of any note height
and then ends with GG because we don't
care about the strength we also look at
targets that i mean a sequences that
match the reverse complement of that
pattern because it is damn we don't care
about the strength now in terms of when
meant by suitable exon is that here we
want to knock out a gene so that means
we only going to consider exons that are
shared between all the isoforms of that
gene that's because we want to just look
at all the different versions of that
gene of course for different
applications that rule might change but
in case of knocking out a gene that
that's a very important criteria we have
to take into account
once we've done that once we've
extracted the sequence isn't much that
pattern we know that all the potential
crisper targets for that gene are in the
list so the only thing we have to do now
and of course it's it's a very important
thing is to go through that list and
remove what we consider it might be bad
targets um and they're going to be bad
either because then we think they're not
going to be efficient or because we
think then they're not going to be safe
it so step one extract all the
candidates and then all the remaining
steps are about filtering that list that
where at the end we only left with what
we think are going to be safe and
efficient targets the first step is to
remove multiple matches because Allison
before we want to knock out the chain
we're interested in but we want you
don't want to modify anything else so we
need to have a very high degree of
confidence on where we're going to make
the cut so if we have the guide put in
Canada the sequence that we detected
more than once when we extracted the
sequence we reject it because we already
know it's not unique and then what we do
is that all the sequences that's passed
that that first test we align each of
them we can see entire genome music
using both side too and if the
candidates has more than one exact match
we reject the targets because if we use
that targets while we're going to have a
cast in the chain that we like but also
somewhere else in the genome and say
stories suitable target step three we
looking at the GC content so at the time
before when we sat in the project there
were different guidelines about what
would be a good GC content for the
target many of them work work on think
conflicting instead of at the time which
is a please for logistical enough at
least 55% and also all the targets
that's failed to meet these criteria
Harry
rejected and in practice it's probably
better to avoid extremes so at the
moment which is am running different
tests of the method with different
ranges so for instance the GC content
between 25 and 35% in practice when we
look at the results it looks like the
targets that could have an extreme GC
content even if did but if based on the
criterion we use here the past that step
they would usually fail somewhere else
either because they end up having
partial matches somewhere else or
because they have a very poor secondary
structures or finish things like that so
it looks like that step even though it's
it's filtering many targets in practice
TM if we removing the these rejected
targets could be rejected somewhere else
for different reason so now we might it
looks like the exact value here is looks
super importance in step four we remove
the targets that contain that put them
in sub sequence because it's
transcription Terminator changer
sequences of my colleagues wanted to
eliminate them the advantages as for the
GC contents it's something that's very
easy to detect and so it's a step that
is going to very quickly eliminates
targets and because overall the method
is quite computationally expensive it's
nice to have some steps that are
actually quite fast cuz the more targets
we reject early on
what the less things would have to do
with them let natural so - yeah it's
always worth removing things quickly
where we can instead fire if we look at
the M we take into account the primers
that were used in the experiments that
we were doing and so here we give you
the sequence of T reverse primer that
migrates what we're using and so they
wanted to avoid
targets that were too close to that
primer so what we need is that for every
sequence that made it that far
we calculate the similarity between that
sequence and the reverse primer and if
the two similar we just reject the
target of course not everyone is going
to use that primer went with a building
that the guides and so p.m. we have the
ability to switch off that steps if it's
not longer relevant
now in step six we look at the secondary
structure in the reason why we do that
is that TM secondary structure of the
guide RNA is very important for the
efficiency of TM of the targets and the
m23 base-pairing cleaned up a motif that
you generate what is important to bind
to TM reach and your targeting but the
rest of the guide is important to bind
to Gaston and bring cast line to make
the cut
and so TM what we do is that we generate
the entire sequence for the guide RNA so
including the targets
interp the rest of the guide we
calculate the secondary structure of
that entire sequence and then if the
part of the guy that's used to bike to
gas now it has a pore structure in if
that structure is stable enough based on
on TM energy then we discard that
targets because we say that well it's
nothing to be efficient because it won't
be able to point correctly to cast light
so once we've cleared step 6 we only
left with targets that we think are
going to be efficient the other thing we
need to check of course as I mentioned
at the beginning is how safe they're
going to be so we took that into account
already to some extent in step 2 when we
remove the multiple matches but what we
know is that there are other sites in
the genome that's where the guide might
steal points because it has subtract
only a partial mismatch and sodium there
are different strategies to look at that
some people just count the number of
sites that have
mismatched compared to you guys know
both sides have two mismatches three
mismatches and so on but TM there was an
interesting paper from Feng Teng group
in Nature Biotechnology in 2013 that
looked at TM specificity of
optiom of the binding and they found
that TM that specificity doesn't depend
just on the number of the mismatches
also the positive that mismatch
important the way the data is that it
took one sequence identity generated
multiple sequences with just one
mismatch at different positions or two
mismatched sheets at different position
three and so on and they had say the
binding efficiency and based on these
experimental results what they came up
with is full an inner scoring system
so the rule is that they on this we need
to worry about loss for me
so for each target we and then they have
a scoring system based on the number of
mismatches and where that mismatch is
located and so you can see W at the
bottom you have the exact scores so the
position of the mismatch is going to
have an influence on the score so for
instance the first value in W is 0 which
means that well that's a mismatch here
is going to have the beginning impact
well if you have if you close to the end
of the body you have points point eight
zero for while because you take 1 minus
W well that's is closer to 0 and so the
amount of Tad's mismatch and in terms of
the risk is is going to be smaller and
so what we do is that we use that score
to evaluate the software a local risk so
it's the risk between your candidate and
one other sequence somewhere else in the
inter genome that has at most four
mismatches okay so for all
deep sequences that have a double atlas
for mismatches compared to you
candidates you get that's local school
and then in the second step you combine
all these local scores and that gives
you using that formula and that gives
you the global score for you candidates
that score is between zero and one and
the higher it is the less likely you are
to have off target modification in that
paper the food threshold around 0.6 I'm
saying that if it's if the score is
higher than 0.6 the target should be
fine but as I said at the beginning we
took the approach of being very strict
about our filtering steps and so we
decided to use let's go of 0.75 as the
threshold so if the target has a score
below 0.75 we said TM there might be
some risk of of toilet ratifications and
so we reject the targets that process is
the most expensive parts and
compassionately speaking because we have
to evaluate to compare the guy our
candidate with all the other possible
sites in the genome and in the mammalian
genome you would have hundreds of
millions of possible sites and so that's
very slow but DM the way we improved it
is that we don't really care about the
exact score if it is going to be 0.75
and so we have an early cutoff point
when we calculate that score as soon as
it drops below 0.75 we recheck the
target and we don't try to actually
calculate the exact score and by doing
that we save quite a bit of time once
we've done that all the contestants have
made it this far into TM
section process are what we consider
suitable targets which check that we're
happy they're going to be efficient we
check that your target risky is low
enough science targets we're happy to
use so what we do is we save these
targets along with the exact location
all the properties we assess so we
the second researcher we safety of tacit
scorn so we said all that into a file
and then that file is used to build a
database that contains all the targets
from the entire genome so DM we've
released at 40m mouse genome it's
available at Chris Pratt Rick & ojb
insert in terms of stats what we found
is that for most genes we found a lot of
targets so some genes we've found even
with these tricks strict rules we found
hundreds of targets but interesting
famous that's for actually roughly 72
percent of the genes we found at least
six targets until in the context of
triple targeting strategy that's
something that's quite useful because
that means you can reproduce your
results you can use three targets to
generate your knock out and then if you
find an interesting phenotype well you
can generate new knockouts using a
different sets of three targets and then
check your if you observe the cell
phenotype and by doing that you're
reducing the risk that the the phenotype
that you observe is because of an oft
against modification because it's very
unlikely that the independent center of
targets would have the same oft against
modification because the targets are
different so having for most of the
genes that ability to have multiple sets
of triple targets it is very valuable
and overall you have we have more than
80% of TM of the genes for which we have
at least three so we can use the triple
targeting and then four we have under
20% who we have less than I mean between
zero and two targets and so within that
most most genes have at least what one
one target so that means we cannot use
the triple target language can still
target them
using traditional approaches so we use
that strategy a lot so I'm just going to
go through some results which we've had
with knockout mice in the sleep context
so the first thing that we checked is
that our tears in a snuck out so if you
remember it's the one we just changed
the color of the fur have no more sleep
and they do they have similar behavior
to wild-type which is reassuring it
means Sweden's been changing the
currents and affected sleep which is as
we expected and then we looked at
traditional and clock not gas so we can
be more knockouts and chromatic right
you and / 1 / 2 double knockouts and we
observe TM similar results what had been
reported in the literature using
traditional Nuggets methods then we
looked at TM appropriate in mice then
they have a fragmented sleep which is
what we expect it because that's the
gene responsible for narcolepsy and so
with all these different night headlines
that were generated we were confident
that we could use that's triple
targeting strategy to have efficient
first-generation knockout and so based
on that strategy that's we were happy
wait at that stage and I wouldn't tell
other genes
instead we identify it's NR 3 a as a
short sleep and gene so ahead of time
gene is reducing sleep by more than an
hour and a half
what we found is that TM what's changed
is TM is the transition between from
work to to to sleep so TM and once the
mice are asleep they seek normally but
it takes them longer to fall asleep the
interesting thing is that because we
have multiple targets based thanks to
our detection method
we were able to reproduce the results
with a different set of three targets
still to make sure we looked at of
targets modifications we couldn't find
any and then we lose we did a mass spec
analysis and confirmed that the protein
were SAP cells so we were able to really
be sure that the phenotype that we're
observing was because of TAS and
specific knockout and then we took it
further stealing into sleep context and
look at those different genes
quite different channels and bumps
related to calcium channels and so for
each of these same thing we're able to
use our first set of three targets
generate the knockout detect the
interesting phenotype in the first
generation use a different set of three
targets first-generation knockout and
confer confirm this the same phenotype
so very quickly in the space of a few
years we looked at maybe more than 30
different knockouts were previously each
individual knockout would have taken
months and month so it's really
completely changed the way the lab was
was able to operate um so if you want
more details tease all these different
knockouts were reporting in these two
articles in Cell reporter in neuron
couple of years ago of course when we
started developing our methods the
reason why we had to develop our method
was that there wasn't so many tools that
we could use but since then that has
changed many people got interested into
DM by informatics side of Chris Berg and
so we recently started comparing our
method against other methods are now
available in what we found is that our
method is relatively fast we can get
back to that in a second but there are
some tools that still fat faster than
what we're doing and so we we want to
sort of try to see how we can we can
improve our method and what we also
found is that we report fewer targets
that many other tools on average maybe
one-fifth of what's many to other tools
who would report but we don't really see
that as a disadvantage of our methods in
anything it's probably a good thing and
it's a consequence of having very strict
features many targets that's other tools
would we would report we reject and we
think that we rejected them for a good
reason
especially for instance if it surrounds
off targets rinsed we think it's better
to be strict and reject them and also
because the am/pm scoring method that we
use for the off target risk has been
experimentally validated it is based on
that Nature Biotechnology paper from
from 2013 we've quite sure that we that
we evaluating the risk correctly and so
we think it's probably a good idea to if
we think there's enough taiga trees
could just not show that staggered at
all instead of the approach taken by
some tools which is to report all of the
targets and just tell you well this
target has one as well X number of sites
with one mismatch my number of sites
with two mismatches and so on which
might be difficult for DM for the user
of these tools to interpret whether
that's a bad thing or not what's what's
the limit what's the threshold should I
use that targets or is it going to be
risky so I think it's better to
eliminate to really evaluate a priori
the targets and just not sure at all the
ones that we think are going to be at
risk of having off target modifications
in terms of things we still working on
as I said deep method is quite expensive
so at them in terms of compressional
cost at the moment it takes roughly 12
days to process a whole mammalian genome
and if you're doing one of analysis of a
reference genome that's probably fine I
mean for the most you know one took us
12 days but now we don't have to do it
ever again
we
all the targets for the mm10 genome so
that's fine for reference mammalian
genomes um but some reference genomes
can be quite large especially for
flowering plants and so that our current
methods for these Dino's would still
take weeks or maybe month so that's this
is not that ideal but there are also
some applications self long-term
applications for instance in precision
medicine where we would work with non
reference genomes and so we need to if
you're working with multiple genomes
like this you want to analyze each of
them when you probably don't want to
wait 10 or 12 days every time and so
much of our current work is focused on
making our method faster and so our
objective is to basically bring that our
current methods to less than a day to
process million genome that sort of
benchmark and anything is going to be
perfect if it's feasible the other
things we're working on is TM tag and
scoring and that's because TM sure we
designed the method to filter out
targets so all the ones that are left
with fairly happy with this might still
be useful to rank the ones that we keep
it's not because then we they're all
going to be efficient we think that
they're all going to be equally
efficient there might still be things
that differentiate them and so there are
some tools that that have some
efficiency scoring for instance between
machine learning and so we're trying to
see how we can incorporate elements of
Tad's
into our methods and the other thing is
that we're moving past knockouts because
in our method the only thing that's
specific to knock out is the triple
targeting but all the the actual
selection steps for TM for the target
design can be generalized and so for
instance we've worked on producing a map
for over the whole genome the whole
human genome we pretty soon
a map of targets that allele-specific
for the MK 562 encodes cell line so the
idea here is that we have the same
featuring steps the only thing that's
different is step one instead of looking
at excellence that are shared between
extra forms of a chain we want to knock
out we're looking at all the other
specific sites across the whole genome
and then we only look at targets in
these regions with the rest of the
method can be easily generalized so in
summary while CRISPR because it's easy
to use and it offers in theory high
efficiency it has completely changed the
way the care clients are produced in in
Mouse research and of course it changed
anything as a whole and so it's really
changed how people in the second or
sleep fields are working and what we've
shown is that by using specific
strategies such as the triple targeting
we can have a very very high no Kara
efficiency even in the first generation
with TM what that means is that we need
to have access to several targets for
potentially a very large number of genes
if you're looking at complex pathways
and so we developed an automated method
to detect all these targets and as I
mentioned the advantage of tactics
automatic method is that we can also
increase the reproducibility of the work
because it's easy to just reproduce the
results with different sets of targets
because you have all of them available
whenever you want another type method is
has been validated and has been giving
good results with focusing on improving
that method and applying it to further
domains and with that I just want to
thank you all for your attention and
give a big thanks as well to all my
collaborators on the experimental side
who make all that work possible Thanks
and thank you dr. Carrie include honor
under the presentation we will now start
the Q&A portion of our webinar all
addressed some was commonly asked
questions by our viewers
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on that
ask a question drop-down box located on
the far left of your presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen and click that send
button our speakers will follow up with
you with your questions via email so
let's take a look at our viewers
questions dr. Barron what if a gene has
few or no targets that pass all
filtering steps sooner I mean approach
is to be quite straight in that and we
found that spam as I mentioned for more
than 80% of the genes even with these
very strict rules we can generate enough
targets to have two people to use our
triple targeting strategy but DM idea is
that well it's nice to be strict
initially but many of these rules can be
be made more flexible so if there is a
specific gene that we want to target and
with these very strict rules we don't
find anything then we can just rerun the
method just for that gene with some
relaxed rules and we know that there is
a risk in doing that but it's we only do
it for the genes for which we don't have
enough targets so we have the ability to
on demand rerun the method for just
specific genes with relaxed rules to
search we find something thank you
preparing how can speed be improved so
at the moment so in the 12 days the
slowest the two slowest steps are the
last one so DM the secondary structure
analysis and and especially the off
tagging scoring is really the slowest
one in as I was mentioning it's because
for each candidates that we're
evaluating in theory we have
to compare it with all the possible
sites in the whole genome and then check
from each of them do we have less than
four mismatches and if yes then we have
this correct and because in a millions
you know we have purchasing indeed a
mouse genome we have 245 million such
sites one for each candidate will have
to do that 245 million times but then
surely and so that's what takes a long
time but what we're working on is
basically clustering strategies - for
one candidate size only consider the
size that will we know will have less
than for mismatch is sort of
pre-processing steps so instead of
scoring one guide against 245 million
and size we only screw it against the
sides that we know are going to be a
risk so basically we focusing on
pre-processing methods to speed up that
that step and because we spend most of
the time in that step and any
improvement that we make is going to
drastically reduce of all the time
so we think it's quite realistic to to
aim for processing the whole genome in
less than a day
we also focusing on optimizing the code
so part of it is therapy in Python which
is was easy - I mean it was easy to
develop doctor for initial development
when it's not necessary the most
efficient programming language it's a
reporting part of that code you see
which is also going to give a
performance boosts thank you for that
and don't recurring can the method be
applied to any organization I'm sorry
organism
yes sodium sodium most of the initial
work that we've done with some on the
mouse genome because that's what the
group was using but there's nothing in
the method that's specific to the mouse
genome so it can be used with any
organism so since and since then we've
worked on human cells for instance k562
is a human cell line with we're also
working with back
with plans and so there's nothing
specific and to the mouse in our method
basically any organism for which you
have the genome as an input we can run
the method on it sorry Barry thank you
so much for your presentation today
would you like to provide our viewers
with a closing remark yeah I'm Indian
Satyam as I said the m-40 genomes that
we've already analyzed so Francis from
the mm10 genome there is a completely
available database where you can just
query any gene that you're interested in
but what we're also working on is really
some of the codes that if you have one
genome that you're particularly
interested in that is not available
online you can just download the code
and run it directly on your genome so
that's going to come up shortly Sophie
and if you're interested you can just
send me an email and then give you the
link once once it's released dr. Perry
thank you again for your presentation
today and for your important research
I'd also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before I go I want to remind
everyone that today's webcast will be
available on-demand viewing through
January 2019 you'll receive an email
from lab roots letting you know when
this webcast will be available for
replay please share this announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now and
thanks for joining us we hope to see you
again soon bye bye